president kicking off his second year in
office with a nearly two-hour press
conference yesterday of quite a marathon
the president defending his record
despite his major agenda items
repeatedly falling short in congress
here to talk about it is white house
press secretary jen saki great to have
you and we have so much to cover with
you i want to start with the voting
rules good morning to you jen by the way
it's hard to find two bengal fans in the
same room
that's right and we've done it can i
join the party game this weekend big
game on saturday go bagels
and hopefully there will be no breaking
news that you have to deal with jen
during the bengals game we will try to
protect you from thanks for being here
let's start with voting rules uh you
just tweeted this i want to put it up
here it says let's be clear the
president was not casting doubt on the
legitimacy of the 2022 election he was
making the opposite point in 2020 a
record number of voters turned out in
the face of a pandemic and election
officials made sure they could vote and
have those votes counted
but here's what the president said
yesterday afternoon
well it all depends on
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
the increase
in the prospect of being illegitimate is
the direct proportion of us not being
able to get these
these reforms passed last night on the
eve of his anniversary in office those
reforms failed so i'm curious if he will
continue to say that those 2022
elections will be illegitimate
well first i've talked to the president
a lot about this and he absolutely is
not predicting uh that the 2022
elections would be illegitimate the
point he was raising was both that in
2020 even amongst challenging
circumstances efforts to suppress the
vote and
the midst of a pandemic there was record
turnout democrats and republicans record
turnout to go to the polls and the point
he was making is that the former
president asked a number of states seven
or more in fact to overturn the outcome
of the election now obviously if there's
an effort to do that we've got to fight
against that that's what our commitment
is to doing but he was not making a
prediction he has confidence in the
american people and we're going to do
everything we can to protect people's
rights he mentioned the minority vote i
mean he was pretty brash about it and
you're right we have the largest turnout
we've seen on a percentage basis in 120
years and states are changing their own
laws as we speak joe biden's lived in
delaware for 70 years and they're going
to have early voting for the first time
this coming november in 22. and bill it
should be a baseline everybody should
have access to early voting you know if
you're a parent of two kids or three
kids i have two some people three four
more it is challenging you should have
more places you can drop off your ballot
you should have more places you can
early vote that should be a baseline
everywhere across the country and as it
relates to the minority vote we know
that voter suppression impacts minority
communities the most part of what the
john lewis voting rights act is trying
to do is make it harder for states that
have a history of that to change their
laws to make it even more difficult they
have to get approval from the department
of justice we think that's entirely
reasonable and i will say that a lot of
republicans in the past 16 who are still
in the senate today have supported the
protection of voting rights in the past
so his question is why wouldn't this be
a bipartisan effort all right well this
this issue will certainly continue you
know in addition here in new york the
city council just passed a bill saying
that non-citizens can vote even if they
just got here 30 days ago so i mean the
question about legitimacy of elections
does that go both ways right i mean
we're going to have a lot of talk about
that but i also want to ask you about
covid
we're about six weeks behind europe when
it comes to these variants that are
coming through that was true with delta
is true with omicron yesterday europe
made some very interesting decisions
boris johnson in the uk rolling back
mass mandates and vaccine passports
israel's saying we're not going to make
everyone get a booster every three
months you had spain doing something
similar on vaccine passports even the
czech republic
so
the president seems to be going in a
different direction right we're sending
out you're sending out mass now you're
going to do the test
but can you envision will the president
provide america an off-ramp
to kovid and especially for those the
unvaccinated because more we find out
from the cdc saying that it does you are
more protected if you already had the
virus even if you are unvaccinated that
just came out so
i'm looking for a question or an answer
on an off-ramp for americans because a
lot of unvaccinated feel like they're
being the scapegoats and second class
citizens even though i want people to be
vaccinated so that they're protected
sure well first let me say 75 of the
country is fully vaccinated all of those
people did not vote for joe biden and
certainly they're not all democrats we
know that mathematically what the
president's trying to do is protect the
country protect people from death we
also know in in from the cdc and from
our scientists that you are 17 times
more likely to be hospitalized and 20
times more likely to die if you are not
vaccinated so we're trying to provide
people accurate information at the same
time dan i think you make a really
important point we don't want to live
like this you heard the president say we
don't want to live like this forever we
want to get back to a point where we're
not wearing masks of course where we're
not worried about our kids being in
school places where we can go and cheer
for the bengals that one's for you bill
out in football stadiums that's where we
want to get to and what we're trying to
do is continue to fight at the height of
a pandemic to get to that point
six weeks so are we about six weeks away
from something like a boris johnson
announcement saying that mass will no
longer be required maybe less
well i i can't make a prediction of that
because we listen to the scientists
obviously we've seen uh it spike in some
parts of the world we're seeing it spike
we've seen spikes and come down a little
bit in some parts of the united states
but we'll be watching it very quickly
okay on the border now it did not come
up yesterday um yet in 2021 we believe
there were two million encounters at the
southern border
i'm just blowing away all kinds of
records
there does not
seem to be much of a suggestion that the
policy is going to change should we
expect two million more encounters in
the year 2022 now
well i'm surprised bill as well because
it was a nearly two hour press
conference and people asked whatever
they wanted including some crazy
questions in there but i will say bill
what the president's view is is that we
need to do more we need to fix our
broken immigration system that means
smarter security
at the border it also means a more moral
approach to how we're treating people
when they come across the border now
some of those confrontations at the
border mean we still have issues
in these countries that have been going
on for a long time this is why we see
surges every couple of years where
people have challenging economic
circumstances uh and they're not and we
haven't done enough to address the root
causes that's part of what we're focused
on as well but we need to address this
from many people you've got criminals
who are being arrested at the border on
a weekly basis
uh and you're well aware of that all
right onto crime dana go ahead well that
was another issue that didn't come up
last night but it is starting to show up
in the top five issues that voters say
that they're concerned about and you can
also look at the polls that say that
they there a majority of people feel
that the president is not focused on the
issues that they care about so on crime
will the president find a way back to
where he was when he supported the crime
bill i mean people are concerned about
the murder rate but also assaults
burglary everything it seems like it's
on edge and you can't think about
anything else like free community
college or universal pre-k if you're
worried about your security
well absolutely the president would
agree with you on that front and we have
also encouraged local leaders local
officials to take on the crime in their
communities that's absolutely essential
what the president has proposed and
we'll get to there'll be a lot of
discussion of this i expect over the
next couple of months is a significant
plus up of funding for a local community
policing programs significantly
increased from from the last president
but generally because the president's a
believer in that well he pushed on the
progressive prosecutors that are for
example here in new york city saying
that things like using taking a gun into
a store robbing it but then leaving and
nobody gets killed that that's a
misdemeanor is the president okay with
that
well look the president's not going to
wade into uh the actions of prosecutors
or of the legal justice department
that's his bottom line but he's also
been very clear he's been a long time
supporter of cops programs of the police
of local first responders of local law
enforcement and he has been an advocate
for additional funding as you know it
was a big issue of defunding the police
that was absolutely never anything he
proposed or supported including even in
the face of uh of real criticism from
within him okay two more topics here on
russia what would the white house
consider to be a quote minor incursion
well let me be very clear on what the
president has conveyed directly to
president putin if there is any movement
of military troops across the border
into ukraine if that is uh if they go
into ukraine and invade that is an
invade that is an invasion there will be
severe economic consequences it is also
true and bill i was at the state
department and dane i was at the state
department back in 2014. we saw some of
this back then there's a range of
tactics the russians use whether it's
the little green men as they're called
or it's cyber attacks and we will be
prepared to respond uh to that as well
so we're prepared for a range of tactics
they may use but if they move their
military into ukraine we will be
responding and we have a range of
preparations as you know from overnight
kiev was i i think the word were shocked
by some of their leading diplomats when
they heard that comment
has there been a direct communication
with kiev today uh since that comment
last night about a minor incursion
our national security team has been in
touch tony blinken is in europe right
now also i would note the foreign
minister conveyed just this morning that
he is confident in the support of the
united states and he should be because
we are supportive when we have their
backs back here now he he said he and a
lot of this was framed in the last 12
months coming up on one year in office
he said he outperformed in his first
year
what would progressive lawmakers say to
that comment
you'll have to have them on your channel
and have and ask them but i would say
bill what he was referring to is the
fact that no one thought he would get in
a bipartisan infrastructure bill across
the finish line and as you know he did
that with the support of 19 senators and
six members of the house no one thought
that we would make as much progress on
covet as we did are we still in the
midst of the fight absolutely but 210
million people 75 of the country is
vaccinated that's progress we can build
on as dana knows well and you know well
from covering white houses you don't
pack up your bags after one year you
keep working on it and that's exactly
what we're going to do so that was the
point i just want to backtrack a moment
here because we're doing this interview
in real time and in real time zolensky
the president of ukraine just sent out
this tweet i want to read it to you i
know it you haven't seen it yet i
haven't seen it yet we'll read it i
haven't seen it yet so we want to remind
the great powers that there are no minor
incursions and small nations
just as they're though
just as there are no minor casualties
and little grief from the loss of loved
ones i say this as the president of a
great power
and tweet your reaction to that
well i would be very i would be thank
you for the opportunity let me be very
clear uh the president has conveyed
directly to president putin if there is
the movement of any military troops
across the border that is an invasion uh
if they go in that is an invasion and
there will be severe economic
consequences i know president zielinski
knows that we've conveyed that uh it is
also true as president zielenski has
experienced that there are a range of
tactics the russians use we've been
warning about uh about some of those
steps including the spreading of
misinformation out there which has been
widespread was widespread in 2014 the
use of cyber
tools and we're also going to be ready
to respond to that as well and we'll be
working in lockstep with the uk and the
uh you know certainly other adversaries
of the united states watch everything
that the president says and that you say
so yesterday when the president said
that about minor incursion you can
imagine that everyone in beijing was
thinking
when it comes to taiwan and i wonder
about
that message right how it will spread
even further but also
curious about the olympics does the
president have any concern about the
well-being and safety of american
athletes as they head to china in this
very tumultuous time
uh if if he did we would work with the
u.s olympic committee to address that i
will tell you dana that we made a very
the president made a very clear decision
about not sending a diplomatic
delegation obviously that wasn't for
security purposes that was sending a
clear message about human rights and our
concerns about the treatment of uyghurs
uh however uh we work closely with the
u.s olympic committee the athletes are
going the president's looking forward to
cheering i'm a bit olympic success
obsessed myself and i'm looking forward
to cheering uh for them as well from
home and we hope they stay safe along
the way
i mean it's an extraordinary thing the
world's gonna be watching this country
we still don't have answers on covet the
president yesterday said he brought this
up with president g
how firmly
the president's uh never holds back and
he's always firm in his conversations i
can promise you that including with
president xi who he's known for a long
time he's had a lot of deep direct
conversations with my last question for
you jen you know i have a lot of empathy
for on the press side of things i always
feel like i can like be in the room and
think what you're thinking
when the president said
looks at his watch and says i guess i'll
go another 24 minutes i'm curious what
your exact heart rate was at that time
i'm a pretty chill person in general i
may not always seem that way in the
briefing room um but i will say i knew i
watched and i knew he was having a good
time
he actually likes engaging with
reporters as you all know he was on the
hill for 36 years as a member of the
senate and in congress members wander
around and reporters come up and ask
them questions and that's what he's used
to so i knew he was having a good time i
was having a heart attack for you
listen the build-up for this press
conference went a total of five days
because that's how soon you announced it
uh and if he likes that give-and-take we
would encourage him to join us
we would encourage him to join the white
house press corps more often than just
yesterday but well
thank you
let me tell you the bill he's answered
questions 250 times in the last year to
the white house press corps but i will
see him shortly and i will pass on your
invitation thank you
and thank you for being here today
please come back we'll do it more often
good luck to the bengals everyone
thank you thanks jen i don't know how
well they take that in nashville but
we'll see about that with the titans
this weekend